bueno buenos días a todos vamos a pensar
los próximos momentos sobre nuestra
relación con nuestra ciudad nuestro
sentimiento de pertenencia a una ciudad
eso que nos hace sentirnos orgullosos de
vivir en una ciudad y también vamos a
pensar en nuestra dimensión como
ciudadanos del mundo si tenemos un
poquito de talento y un poquito de
idiomas podemos elegir la ciudad del
mundo en la que podamos desarrollar
mejor nuestro potencial
vamos a intentar explorar esas
posibilidades y ver como el mundo como
las ciudades ahora mismo están en una
competencia global intentando retener y
atraer talento
este este año es el cumple exactamente
un siglo de él
el tratado de versalles que marcó el
final de la primera guerra mundial y por
tanto el final de los imperios antiguos
al acabar la segunda guerra mundial con
las conferencias de postdam y de la alta
en nuestro mundo quedó configurado en un
esquema de países que se consolidó
después con las naciones unidas
señoras y señores bienvenidos a la era
de las ciudades las ciudades son las que
están ahora mismo moviendo el mundo
sobre el motor de la economía son los
entornos que atraen la mayoría de los
ciudadanos que generan la gran cantidad
la mayoría de la riqueza que hacemos a
nivel mundial y también son las
generadoras de un conjunto enorme de
información que hacemos entre todos
entre toda la sensorización de la ciudad
de los datos de los ciudadanos lo que
nosotros vamos haciendo con nuestras
redes sociales con nuestros dispositivos
un conjunto enorme de información este
año vamos a generar más información que
en toda la historia pasada de la
humanidad
intentemos imaginar un poquito eso pero
también las ciudades están intentando
competir por esos 1.700 millones de
millennials que están ahí fuera
decidiendo cuál es la ciudad donde
pueden desarrollarse mejor dónde pueden
hacer su vida dónde pueden hacer que
todo su potencial florezca algo muy
importante y algo por lo que las
ciudades hoy por hoy están compitiendo
esto ha sucedido antiguamente ha
sucedido varias veces en las distintas
revoluciones industriales vemos la misma
ecuación una nueva tecnología liderada
por un país o por una ciudad que atrae
el talento atrae a las personas
talentosas y hacen simplemente cola con
abrir la puerta de la tolerancia tenemos
la receta de la prosperidad lo vimos con
el alimento de watson la máquina de
vapor inglaterra londres lo vimos con
nikola tesla maravilloso inventor con
todos los sistemas de electricidad y de
transmisión de electricidad por las
redes eléctricas que hoy por hoy
consideramos algo habitual y eso lo
lideró eeuu nueva york con la compañía
general electric y otras no después
hemos asistido al nacimiento de los
ordenadores el silicon valley el entorno
de san francisco si aarón todo ese
entorno que ha liderado esta tercera
revolución industrial y ahora estamos en
los albores de la cuarta revolución
industrial
y esto se vuelve a repetir tenemos a las
ciudades intentando competir por ese
liderazgo a ver cuál es la que va a
marcar las pautas de la cuarta
revolución industrial que viene marcada
por esto que vemos aquí las robótica y
la inteligencia artificial y una vez más
para hacer esto posible y necesitamos
talento
que es entre ge artificiales es muy
complejo de explicar pero
fundamentalmente es manejar un conjunto
muy fuerte de información y de datos un
conjunto masivo con una capacidad de
proceso que nos permita hacer eso y eso
lo tenemos con los nuevos sistemas de
nube y finalmente talento el talento
vuelve a padecer el talento como clave
para esta cuarta revolución industrial y
como clave para las anteriores y todas
las ciudades intentando competir por ese
talento y para hacer eso las ciudades
invierten en tecnología y hablamos del
concepto de smart cities y seguro que
habéis oído hablar de todo ello las
ciudades han invertido en tecnología
inicialmente para resolver sus tareas
internas para
y empezaron para los sistemas de
impuestos los sistemas de los recibos
que vamos que vamos pagando nuestras
contribuciones etcétera después con el
conjunto de sexualización de la ciudad
han ido adquiriendo un montón de
información un montón de datos y con
esos datos intentan daros un mejor
servicio toda la información sobre el
tráfico sobre las condiciones
medioambientales ellos intentan
anticiparse e intentan ser predictivos y
dar un mejor servicio al ciudadano pero
se han olvidado del ciudadano
el ciudadano es alguien al que se le
pregunta cada cuatro años no existe una
conexión con ese ciudadano ahora mismo
estamos en el concepto de ciudades o de
smart cities 3.0 intentando hacer ese
giro copernicano donde el centro de los
datos ahora le pongo el centro el
ciudadano el ciudadano en el centro de
la ciudad manejando y dominando la
ciudad y los datos evidentemente son
importantes son necesarios sirviendo a
ese ciudadano de acuerdo y el problema
es que es difícil es difícil conectar y
deciden volver a reconectar con ese
ciudadano es difícil que la ciudad pueda
entrar en vuestros smartphones porque
estamos acostumbrados a que no queremos
que alguien penetre en nuestra intimidad
en nuestros sistemas nos evalúen y
recoge información de nosotros entre
nuestra privacidad permitamos por favor
a la ciudad hacer eso la apelación no va
a intentar vendernos nada va a intentar
darnos un servicio público con el
objetivo en las smart cities 4.0
el sentido de comunidad el sentido de
colmena el sentido colectivo de que
entre todos podamos construir una mejor
ciudad el sentido de co-creación
los ciudadanos se han ido evolucionando
y cambiando aquí podemos ver la última
revolución en solamente 8 años el mismo
evento en la misma ciudad
probablemente con una participación muy
parecida de personas y vemos una gran
diferencia vemos que el ciudadano es un
ciudadano digital y por tanto tenemos
que conectar con el ciudadano de una
forma distinta tenemos que ser enganchar
en la nueva forma de dialogar y mi hija
dialoga seguramente con el dispositivo
yo le digo el smartphone es una cosa que
se ve para llamar por teléfono teléfono
es una palabra y hay una palabra griega
que viene de tele distancia y fono
hablar no va para las nuevas
generaciones el smartphone es un
dispositivo telemático donde mandan
información de acuerdo y se genera una
gran cantidad de información de forma
colectiva hay que hablar en ese idioma
desde el punto de vista de las ciudades
he intentado modelizar
qué hace una ciudad atractiva lleva a la
conclusión de que el proceso es muy
parecido al proceso de determinar una
motivación de compra o tomar una
decisión en favor de una alternativa u
otra y esa decisión esa capacidad de
decisión tiene dos componentes
fundamentales un componente emocional y
un componente racional el componente
emocional viene en el punto de vista de
me gusta la ciudad me siento partícipe
de esta ciudad ese sentimiento de
pertenencia
es una cuestión de gustos ya lo sé pero
está muy arraigada en muchas ciudades
realmente os sentís orgullosos de
vuestra ciudad podríais
y hablar bien de vuestra ciudad y
realmente es una ciudad que os gusta del
punto de vista estético a eso le llamado
el magnetismo
el punto de vista racional
viene a contar si la ciudad para mí
realmente es una buena apuesta si lo que
obtengo de la ciudad comparado con lo
que me cuesta vivir en esta ciudad es
realmente un buen negocio para mí es he
hecho un buen como dicen en inglaterra
he hecho una buena una buena apuesta
viviendo en esta ciudad y eso lo llamo
la rentabilidad
vamos a intentar aproximarnos un poco
estos conceptos
qué hace que una ciudad tenga un
magnetismo para mí es difícil de
modelizar estoy haciendo una tesis
doctoral estudiando 140 ciudades más de
100 parámetros de ahorraríamos
internacionales y modelizar una cuestión
estética una cuestión de gustos es
francamente difícil e intenta aproximar
quién nos atrae de una ciudad desde el
punto de vista de tres componentes por
un lado el pasado lo que es la identidad
de la ciudad eso que no se puede cambiar
de un día para otro eso que ha
conformado lo que hoy por hoy es la
ciudad el presente el dinamismo cómo es
de vibrante la ciudad como me hace que
todos los días me levante como han dicho
antes y me ponga a trabajar en hacer
cosas en la ciudad y finalmente la
estrategia del futuro en esta ciudad
tiene un plan puedo desarrollar aquí mi
potencial como persona vamos a hablar un
poco de cabo nuestros conceptos el
magnetismo
viene determinado por la identidad y esa
identidad está marcada por la historia
por la suma de experiencias colectivas
de los ciudadanos que han vivido en esta
ciudad y que han dejado ahí su historia
sus monumentos sus iconos las formas
básicas de gobierno nos permiten
trabajar o nos permiten vivir una forma
cómoda de una forma donde podamos
desarrollar nuestra personalidad la
reputación está muy bien estudiada y
como todo el mundo sabe es algo que se
trata muchos años en construir y muchos
segundos en destruir
la localización geográfica es muy
importante también las cuestiones
derivada del clima si la ciudad es muy
húmeda o es muy seca si es muy calurosa
o es muy fría eso también condiciona la
identidad de la ciudad el entorno de
alrededor si puedo conectar con un
entorno de economía boyante o de
desarrollo económico fuerte alrededor de
la ciudad y también cuestiones muy
importantes como por qué no la
gastronomía porque no la identidad de la
ciudad como esa ciudad proyecta su
identidad hacia el exterior pensemos en
los las películas
que se quede casa blanca sin casa blanca
o que sería de madrid sin la real madrid
o también el atlético pero es una imagen
proyectada hacia afuera cuantas veces
está mi ciudad en la prensa mundial eso
genera una identidad muy importante vale
vamos a ver si entre todos somos capaces
de entender qué es este concepto de
identidad si yo pongo estos iconos vamos
a pensar en qué ciudad estoy pensando lo
tenemos claro más o menos si además de
pongo a la gastronomía y ponemos el
chocolate college ofrece cervezas y
mejillones yo creo que ahora tenemos un
poco más claro
si además pongo esto está clara cuál es
la ciudad en la que estoy pensando
estos son los iconos esto es esto
compone el branding de esa ciudad esto
es la identidad de esa ciudad que como
dije antes se tarda muchos años en
construir
desde el punto de vista del presente del
dinamismo tiene mucho que ver con la
competitividad con la creatividad que me
permite desarrollar mis actividades
personales la forma que tiene esa ciudad
de tratar al expatriado de acogerle te
permitirá establecer relaciones sociales
porque la dimensión social del hombre
viene desarrollada en la ciudad es la
ciudad la que le capacita es el npd es
la es el entorno que hace que esa ciudad
que esa persona pueda desarrollar esas
conexiones sociales del punto de vista
ético la ciudad me permite ser feliz me
permite tener un balance entre mi vida
laboral y mi vida personal tengo espacio
para el ocio es una ciudad igualitaria
del punto de vista de género
cuáles son los parámetros de pobreza el
balanceo de las clases sociales eso lo
hacen en un índice del profesor italiano
gini que mide la cantidad de clase media
ya no dijo platón en donde publica
cuatro lo importante es tener una clase
media muy fuerte porque la clase media
no compite por el poder ni lucha por
sobrevivir lo que hace es construir
ciudad por eso es tan importante la
clase media
y finalmente el futuro la innovación
sabes cuál es el plan de vuestra ciudad
para los próximos diez años o veinte
años
si no lo sabéis tenéis un problema y
tiene un problema a vuestra ciudad de
acuerdo
ya hemos visto la parte emocional y la
parte racional
dándole vueltas a este asunto pensando
sobre este asunto y estudiando los 3000
años de filósofos que tenemos nadie ha
pensado en lo que es el contrato de
ciudadanía
todos tenemos un contrato de ciudadanía
un acuerdo implícito mediante el cual la
ciudad me da una serie de servicios y yo
le pago a la ciudad una serie de
contribuciones no solamente en impuestos
que nos da la ciudad lo que tenemos aquí
nos da una gobernanza educación
empleabilidad salud servicios sociales
sostenibilidad y medioambiente
conectividad muy importante 5g una suena
un poco eso no emplear términos
tecnológicos desarrollo urbanístico
cultura turismo movilidad urbana muy
importante y seguridad esto lo que me da
a la ciudad y que le doy yo a la ciudad
pues yo en esa ciudad tengo un salario
medio tengo unos impuestos directos
contribuciones sociales con ese dinero
voy a comprar cosas pago unos impuestos
indirectos tengo una capacidad de compra
eso es lo que yo le doy a la ciudad
directamente a cambio de estas
prestaciones que me da la ciudad este es
mi contrato de ciudadano
hice una encuesta el pasado noviembre en
la feria más grande a nivel mundial
sobre smart cities las más city expo en
barcelona a las 21.000 asistentes y me
puse estos 10 grupos de prestaciones de
la ciudad les pedí que me lo valorarán
para mi sorpresa en el entorno más
valorado es la movilidad urbana y eso me
hizo reflexionar
realmente una ciudad del punto de vista
ontológico es un espacio un punto en el
espacio-tiempo donde la gente se
encuentra la ciudad lo que permite es
encontrarnos es desarrollar nuestra
nuestra faceta social somos animales
sociales de acuerdo la ciudad es una
suma de evidencias es una suma de esta
experiencia es el pasado y la ciudad que
necesita o nos ayuda a conectar los unos
con otros por eso la gran importancia de
la movilidad urbana veis que después en
los servicios sociales sostenibilidad la
seguridad después la educación la
empleabilidad
no hay mucha diferencia entre todos
ellos no pensemos que los servicios
culturales son los menos apreciados no
están tan lejos pero si en esta escala
nos da una una idea de qué es lo que más
aprecian los ciudadanos vale bueno vamos
a pensar un poquito sobre esto vamos a
acabar con esta reflexión primero voy a
pensar en ese contrato que tengo de
ciudadanía realmente me compensa vivir
en esta ciudad estoy pagando mucho por
los servicios que obtengo podría irme a
otra ciudad y desarrollar mejor mi
potencial
vamos a revisitar ese contrato y segundo
no podemos ser actores pasivos no
tenemos que pensar lo mismo que dijo jfk
de su país de eeuu pensemos lo de
nuestra ciudad no esperes lo que la
ciudad da por ti piensa también que
puedas hacer tú por tu ciudad tienes que
ser una un actor activo
desde el punto de vista de contribuir de
opinar de
de reportar cosas que piensas que pueden
mejorar
de no ser alguien que simplemente
deposita un voto o su confianza una vez
cada cuatro años de ser alguien que
realmente contribuye al desarrollo de su
ciudad
ser co creadores de nuestra nuestra
ciudad y finalmente como dijo jane
jacobs no podemos
pensar en una ciudad que de cosas para
todo el mundo
si no tenemos una ciudad que ha sido
construida por todos nosotros seamos
capaces por tanto de evaluar nuestro
contrato de ciudadano
decidir cuál es la ciudad que va a
ayudarnos mejor a desarrollar nuestro
potencial y por otro lado seamos
generosos y participemos en la ciudad
ayudemos a que nuestra ciudad sea mejor
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]